Hurray, you're done implementing
wire frames for the app.
Now comes the visual polish part,
where we tweak the styles
and the views to make
the app look awesome.
Here's the visual mocks,
for what the app should look like
when we're done.
If you work with a designer,
they should also give you redlines.
Redlines specify everything from sizes,
font styles, colors, spacing, etc.
This should help you achieve
pixel perfect layouts
that match the visual mocks.
How did we come up with these values?
Well we used the Android design guide
which has information
on metrics and grids,
and we adapted them
to fit our app's needs.
You can click on the link for more info.